hello everyone and welcome to the first
match we are going to cover from the
semi-finals of the Julius bear
generation cup it is Vincent kymer the
newest member of the 2700 Club against
world champion Magnus Carlsen so uh
basically facing the the ultimate
Challenge already in the semi-finals and
uh well it's uh it was an incredible
match we are going to cover the fourth
game but the entire match was truly
spectacular in game one where Magnus had
the white pieces uh Vincent played you
know such an incredible game it was like
it was like watching a World Chess
Championship Match such uh such a
spectacular uh you know game to see uh
game two also very nicely played by both
of them ended in a draw and then in game
three Magnus was able to grind out a win
with the white pieces in in a very very
tough end game he missed the win uh
somewhere in the in in the middle of the
end game Evans and found a brilliant
brilliant defense but then later on he
was able to outplay him he was up a pawn
and he was able to cherish it you know
all the way and this is now game four
Vincent has the white pieces and he must
win in order to force tie breaks against
Magnus so let's check it out it's quite
a quite a peculiar game Let's dive
straight into it so Vincent has the
white pieces and he opens with C4 he
goes for the English opening Knight to
F6 with Knight to F3 and now Pawn to C5
by Magnus we have Knight to C3 E6 with
E3 and D5 uh sorry D5 uh striking in the
center D4 by Vincent now transposing
into the into the semi tarash of the
Queen's Gambit and A6 by Magnus so
there's a whole lot of theory on this of
course uh both of them know this very
very well so characters captures and
here uh most popular is Bishop D Cuban
mag but Vincent goes for G3 saying that
he will finchetto uh his light core
Bishop instead and Magnus pushes C4 so
kind of abandons this the fight for the
center but he has a very clear idea of
what he's doing of course Bishop to G2
Bishop to B4 by Magnus and now there are
a few games that reach this position but
really just a few for example Knight the
E5 is a normal castles is a known move
uh there is a game between Fabiano
caruana and Jordan fan Forest where uh
Bishop the D2 was played that game ended
in a draw but here Vincent throws in a
nice Queen to A4 check and it is now as
of move nine that we have a completely
new game so the king is in check of
course the bishop is hanging only move
if you don't want to lose the game is
Knight to C6 prevents check and also
defends the bishop uh Knight to E5 now
putting pressure on the Knight on C6 and
the Magnus just castles signaling that
he is uh well ready to give up the the
C6 Pawn although it cannot be captured
right away as you'll see Knight captures
and C6 is played Bishop captures and C3
winning the E4 square B captures and not
B captures and C6 and grabbing the pawn
now would be too dangerous because after
Queen captures and C6 yes you are
attacking The Rook but look at this
queen A5 and now uh there's well it's a
pretty bad position for white uh the the
C3 Pawn is hanging if you grab the Rook
Queen captures and C3 comes with check
then this Rook Falls and it's just not
fun so if you Castle Bishop F5 and now
uh the The Rook is protected by the
other Rook the Rooks are nicely
collected connected you're gonna develop
the Rooks the bishop covers B1 so Rogue
B1 is impossible Queen puts pressure on
C3 on on A2 so it's quite a tough
position to play for white so instead
after B captures and C6 events and
castles to safety he says all right I
will not grab the C6 pawn bishop to F5
by Magnus grabbing hold of this
beautiful diagonal and now Bishop to A3
putting pressure on The Rook here also
connecting The Rook to Rook to E8 and
now uh Vincent boldly cleans the C6 pawn
queen captures on C6 and now what can
Magnus do to take advantage of this uh
Pawn grab well he starts with a rook to
E6 attacks the queen and asks Vincent
what do you want to do now you could go
to B7 but it looks like a weird Square
for the queen so then and goes back
Queen to A4 although you can play it for
example if Queen B7 you can't really go
some like Rook B6 because then Queen E7
forces a queen trade uh or rather offers
a queen trade and white is perfectly
fine but of course Rook B6 is not
mandatory you can play Rook to B8 to
give up the A6 Pawn as well and then uh
you can't give it up even because the
Rook defends it so it would be yeah you
have to put your queen on A7 so okay it
can be played but not spectacular so
okay Vincent goes back Queen to A4 and
not Magnus plays H5 and here with this
H5 move which is the strongest move
recommended by the engine uh Magnus says
that you do have the bishop pair
although your Bishop pair isn't really
doing all that much this bishop pair
heating D5 which is nicely protected
it's not like it's gonna become any sort
of a serious Target and the bishop here
striking empty squares uh it's a fine
Square for the bishop it's just not
doing well that much and the action will
be on the king side so here H3 by
Vincent trying to meet H4 with the G4
and now Bishop to D3 beautiful Square
for Carlson's Bishop attacking the rook
and F1 Rook F to C1 sorry that's not a
C1 Rook after C1 and now Knight the E4
and here you can see just how powerful
the bishop and D3 is uh it's um uh
controlling a whole lot of squares here
and basically uh preventing Vincent from
taking advantage of the on all of the
only open file on the board that is the
B file and here Bishop captures an E4 is
the move you have to play because the
Knight is such a monster piece
uh but uh you kind of know because you
already played a lot of chess games if
you do this you're not winning this game
so Vincent will try something else he
plays Queen D1 we have Queen to G5 by
play by putting the Knight on e4 of
course Magnus also cleared the the room
for the queen to enter the king side and
now Queen to E1 there are some tricks
here maybe Knight captures and F2 and
then of course Queen captures and E3 so
it does make sense to guard the E3 Pawn
Rook 8 to E8 and now King to H2 and here
uh Magnus plays a rook to G6 you could
strike with H4 right away but the Magnus
has a different plan he plays Rook to G6
and here we have Rook a to B1 Vincent is
without a move and like I said he
doesn't want to play Bishop captures on
e4 it is a move but uh you you really
don't expect to get a win here and
Vincent absolutely must win this game in
order to force tie break so he plays
Rook 8 to B1 he offers the exchange and
now Vincent's position is completely
lost so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the absolute
crushing maneuver for magnets while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
Brilliance because even Magnus missed it
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Knight captures and
G3 and now you are thinking well how did
Magnus miss this if that's the first
thing that I thought of well that will
be explained in the second move here F
captures and G3 would be played and now
you were thinking Rook captures on E3
attacks the queen adds another attacker
to the G3 Pawn but here Vincent has the
saving H4 and that's the problem now
Magnus really doesn't have a way of
continuing the attack you could trade of
course on G3 but then you just trade
down you're not winning this and if you
try to keep Queens on the board then
Queen F2 and already you have some
problems here through characters and G3
there's a rook B8 trick and after King
H7 there's Queen captures and F7
preparing Queen to G8 and now Magnus
wouldn't really have anything other than
to force a draw with Rook captures on G2
King captures rookie 2 checking G3 and
queen T3 check looks very nice but there
of course is Queen F3 and now there is
no way to force um anything here the
thing that Magnus missed and I imagine
most of you guys watching this uh I'm
not saying all of you but uh you know
I'm I'm imagining most of you is that
after F characters and E3 there's H4 and
now uh White resigns there's no way to
play this uh whatever you play you're
just getting destroyed uh if you push G4
which is the only move that seems like a
good idea then Rook captures on E3 just
you know blasts uh through the position
the queen is attacked and once you move
the queen there's a rookie two now
attacking the queen and the ones the
queen moves let's say Bishop E4 and here
white resides that's it there's no no
way out of this but Magnus had some 10
minutes on the clock whereas uh yeah
Vincent had like one minute and the
clock so Magnus did not want to invest
too much time he didn't want to allow
Vincent to think on his time he played
Bishop captures who wrote captures and
now just played Queen back to d8 now he
of course is convinced that the position
is winning as he is material and he
doesn't want to risk risk too much so
here again Bishop captures and E4 is
always a move but yeah of course Vincent
will not play this he plays Bishop to B4
tries to close the position and also
guard the C3 Pawn but now Rook the B6
Magnus will shift the attention to the B
file play A5 and then try and break
through the B file we have rooked the C1
of course if instant spots this a queen
to B8 and now Pawn to H4 so you don't
have to worry about H4 anymore uh the
queen was also
um uh serving as a preparation move for
that so here we have A5 by Magnus now
trying to give up a bishop but if you
give up this bishop with Bishop captures
and A5 then Bishop Rook comes to B2 and
then there's no defending df2 df2 Square
so Bishop to A3 guarding the B2 square
and now Rook eat the E6 preparing Rook
to G6 to add more pressure to the white
king side then The Rook will beat the
attacking G3 the Knight the queen I'm
it's just very very hard to deal with
Rook the D1 clearing the C1 Square for
the bishop and now Queen to E8 by Magnus
with Bishop to C1 adding more uh defense
to the E3 pawn and now Rook the B1 so
just winning a whole lot of space here
F3 again Bishop captures an E4 is the
move but yeah of course you are not
expecting to win after that so F3 uh
Knight goes back to D6 and now Bishop to
D2 offers a trade of Rooks but Magnus of
course keeps the Rooks and uh takes uh
takes the the second rank for himself so
Rook B1 we have Rook captures a native
instant has to give up even more
material to keep some chances alive
Queen to C1 and now we have Knight the
F5 putting pressure on the E3 pawn and
now it's now or never you have to push
E4 so Pawn to E4 the captures with f
captures and E4 and now magnesis I'm not
allowing you to keep the strong Center
uh just root capture Sun E4 and what can
Vincent do again Bishop captures here uh
I mean you if you give up this bishop uh
Vincent did not want to give up this
bishop for for a pawn but he doesn't
want to give it up for a rook either so
Bishop to F4 yeah sorry for a knight uh
Bishop to F4 and now just Rook e to E2
attacking the bishop and now there of
course is no saving this position he
tries Rook V8 as the bishop on F4 guards
the guards the B8 Square so he does win
magnus's Queen uh but it is far too late
for such things Rook captures on G2 by
Magnus you could also start with Queen
captures and B8 which would be a whole a
whole lot cooler if Magnus did it this
way but okay Rook characters on G2 it's
basically the same line King H2 and now
Queen captures and B8
uh there's really nothing to do you have
to capture the queen and after the ship
capture is now just Rook H2 check King
G1 Rook uh Rook to G2 check uh King to
F1 only move and now Rook to H1 and he
was in this position on move 41 that uh
Vincent kaimer resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
once The Rook is captured which is your
only move then comes Rook captures and
C1 and now you are just down a full Rook
of course uh there's no point in playing
this
so yeah really uh spectacular showing by
both of them like I said first game if
you have a chance do check it out such
such a brilliant performance by Vincent
with the black pieces against Magnus
playing such a such a spectacular line
he uh he uh played the the same line he
played against in that famous game six
of the world championship match uh that
Nepal lost and Vincent was able to you
know just neutralize it and it it's a
really really a spectacular game so do
check it out if if you guys have the
time but yeah game three Was Won by
Magnus a series series grind and then
game four uh Vincent just had to push a
bit too hard and of course Magnus knew
that Vincent would try this so he took
advantage of it very very early on and
didn't let go of the advantage for the
rest of the game like even here uh of
course Magnus knew that uh you know that
uh Moves Like These of course you're a
chess player you think about those moves
but he has 10 minutes on the clock wins
and has one and he knows Bishop cappers
and B1 is well he will be able to push
for the win so he didn't want to invest
too much time
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh another big
congratulations to all of you who
spotted Knight captures on G3 followed
by H4 not an easy move to find in you
know a limited time so congratulations
on that once again I would like to thank
Stuart Matthews they're a king of Brian
pocket and golden pawn and maybe shakui
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the USB
generation cup until it finishes next
game end match that we are covering is
of course Liam Li versus Arjun Erika
easy so stay tuned for that thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day